henri sterdyniak bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
tout d'abord comment expliquer ces
disparités entre les différentes
économies occidentales
d'abord il pouvoir que les pays n'ont
pas été frappés de la même manière par
copie de 19
la france la belgique l'italie l'espagne
ont été particulièrement frappées et
puis il faut voir aussi que en
contrepartie l'italie l'espagne la
france ont pris de mesures de
confinement particulièrement sévère et
donc naturellement leur économie a été
particulièrement affectée par rapport à
des pays moins touchés comme l'allemagne
qui a pu prendre des mesures plus plus
légère et enfin dernière différence des
pays européens ont mis en place
massivement des mesures de chômage
partiel ce qui fait que les travailleurs
sont ne sont pas considérés comme
chômeurs alors que aux états unis par
contre le chômage partiel a été limitée
et donc les en plus leur le licenciement
est très facile et donc naturellement le
taux de chômage a augmenté beaucoup plus
que dans les pays européens
alors on parle d'un recul de l'activité
économie de 30% mois d'avril contre 19%
dans le monde
est ce que la france est victime de son
exposition aux touristes avec des
secteurs de l'hôtellerie restauration
mais aussi du commerce qui sont restés à
l'arrêt pendant plusieurs semaines la
france est victime surtout du fait qu'
on a pris un confinement on a décidé que
le confinement serait extrêmement
rigoureux et on a dit aux personnes ne
pouvaient rester garder vos enfants que
un certain nombre d'entreprises ont
fermé parce qu'elle n'était pas en
capacité rapidement d'organiser les
gestes barrières parce que haut
si on est un pays dans ça fait beaucoup
de transport en commun qu'il a fallu
arrêter
donc tout ça fait on a une certaine
chute de la production
par contre des pays comme l'italie
l'espagne la grèce eux souffrent
particulièrement de la baisse du
tourisme est un pays comme l'allemagne
souffre lui particulièrement du fait que
le le commerce international a également
fortement chuté pour revenir à la
question de l'emploi on l'a dire pour
protéger le secteur certains états ont
davantage compter sur la flexibilité
comme les etats-unis ou l'allemagne
d'autres massivement investi dans le
chômage partiel 1 c'est le cas de la
france qui a raison l'expérience et le
talent l'expérience de 2008 semble
montrer que il est bon et c'est bien de
compter sur le chômage partiel parce que
dans le chômage partiel
ça maintient au pouvoir d'achat de la
masse des salariés
et puis surtout l'entreprise a la
capacité de rebondir extrêmement
rapidement puisque les lorsque la
demande repart immédiatement les
travailleurs sont disponibles alors que
l'ancien licence ird et des travailleurs
ensuite il faut les récupérer ce qui
peut être ce qui peut être plus plus
délicat tire plus en france comme dans
les pays européens mais plus que dans
les pays européens
on a des procédures de licenciement qui
sont moins faciles que aux etats-unis ou
en grande-bretagne et donc le chômage
partiel est une solution tout à fait
satisfaisante alors on le sait à sa
crise sanitaire mondiale va avoir des
répercussions sur l'économie mondiale
pendant plusieurs années est ce qu'on
peut
surtout comment relancer justement cette
économie mondiale des entière il ya deux
manières la première manière
ça consiste à continuer à aider les
entreprises et les ménages
pendant un certain temps le le retour à
la normale va être très loin des ménages
même s'ils ont accumulé des actifs
involontairement dans durant la crise
parce qu'ils on parle plus consommer les
ménages hésitent encore à retourner à
acheter les gens ont peur d'aller dans
les magasins il on parle enthousiasme
pour pour acheter les entreprises eux
sont dans une très grande incertitude ya
certains secteurs comme l'automobile
l'aéronautique
le tourisme qui y ont eu des
perspectives extrêmement incertaines
extrêmement médiocre dont il va falloir
massivement continuer à aider ceux qui
existent et par ailleurs une stratégie
ça consiste à prendre le tournant vers
une société plus écologique et donc
aider en priorité les entreprises qui
sont d'anti ceux qui sont dans la
transition écologique et au niveau
européen on dit même numérique de
manière à préparer une économie plus
résiliente pour les années à venir donc
on a à la fois il des entreprises
actuellement en difficulté et puis
essayer c'est aux grands partis l'objet
des 750 milliards que l'europe va
développer
on va essayer de susciter des nouvelles
entreprises et des investissements
écologiques ou numérique
henri sterdyniak merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste et animateur des économistes
atterrés